Samantha disait juste qu'ils
scolarisent leur fils à la maison, oh c'est bien intéressant,
nous pensons juste que c'est la seule façon de
s'assurer qu'il reçoive la meilleure
éducation possible, les devoirs écrits
doivent être faits en noir quand
allez-vous faire passer cela à travers votre crâne épais
m.  Morris non,
c'est une retenue, ne vous sentez-vous jamais
comme peut-être qu'il est Oh Missy maintenant ouais le
lycée, c'est plus que des cours
et des devoirs oh bien sûr que ça devrait être le moment le plus
malheureux de la vie d'un garçon a laissé tomber
votre argent face allez petite amie choisissez
votre  genoux hé je peux entrer s'il vous plaît
désolé oh il n'y a pas de frais d'attente d'accord
c'est comme si Emily et Cara ont dit que nous devrions
aller jusqu'au bout qu'en pensez-vous
Wow